what is the
uh playbook of investigative journalism
so walk me through is it something that
applies
an investigative journalist in 911 can
he also go be
investigating to peter nygard and can he
also go into investigating a wall street
you know bernie madoff is the playbook
the identical same playbook
is it slightly different well it's
similar i mean there's a template in
terms of what we do
but it often starts with you know a
reporter's intense interest into
something or
you know 40 years into it as i am you
have a lot of contacts and people who
will say you should look into this
and a lot of the material that i come
across including the nycard
investigation came from somebody who is
involved
sometimes a former local or federal law
enforcement person who does this
privately who's working for somebody
that says you need to take a look at
this
and that's how it starts and you you
verify it sometimes it you know you may
find that it's somebody who's got a
personal interest or a vendetta and you
have to approach that differently than
when you find a case like nygard where
this guy's got to be exposed
and and between the pressure that we put
on him and the other media put on him it
was helpful in terms of getting him
indicted and facing charges what do you
think about what james o'keefe is doing
if you said you're recognizing what do
you think about what he's doing i think
that's in a different category i think
when you're doing something
that's potentially politically motivated
and i don't know him i've been contacted
by some of the people who have worked
for him for different stories i have
typically stayed away from it just
because i have questions about how it
works i don't pretend to have intimate
knowledge about how it works but i know
you know he's got a political bent which
is his right
but that's not how i base my journalism
i don't base it because i believe in one
political party over another i i base it
on justice
i base it on what people are interested
in i base it on my expertise and that
that is a whole different world
that crosses a lot of different
boundaries he thinks he's justified in
crossing those lines i can't agree with
that do you do you like how oliver stone
does it where he just goes from a
curious place and he goes and wants to
find out you know what putin is about he
goes and sits when he wants to find out
what ukraine's all about he goes and he
wants to find out what castro did he
goes in
jfk he goes through do you like the
style he does
i do you just have to remember that it's
one man's opinion sometimes right so
it's point of view it doesn't mean that
that's true it's it's it's a
a work that is based upon one man's
curiosity and his ability to spin a
story so you know jfk wasn't necessarily
all
true
truth-based maybe
event-based but it's his theory on what
happened as long as you keep that in
mind i think it's fine with it i mean
it's really no different than me saying
okay i want to investigate peter nygard
and putting together a team and getting
a production company or me saying we
need to do more predator investigations
or me saying we're going to go after
this guy who's been assaulting the women
on social media or any of the other
stories we have going on right now i
mean
we're we've got this case
that i just was working on last week
um
exposing
uh in a southern state
what appears to be a human trafficking
ring involving
politically connected people and think
about you ever watch the first series of
true detective
yeah matthew mcconaughey yeah yeah
that's what i lived last week damn
that was in real life some say that some
of the best tv ever produced i i thought
it was and now we're in the thick of
exposing it for real if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you